[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today bill is
in Indianapolis hi Bill welcome to the
Ramsey
Show um hi Dave thanks for taking the
call sure what's
up um I want to find out how bad of an
idea it would be to gift my 18-year-old
son my childhood
home okay so you own it free and clear
uh me and my
brother mom your brother wants to give
it to him as well yes my brother uh he
yes he's he's willing to give him his
half um you know I'm willing to give the
property
worth uh roughly right now probably a
hundred okay it needs tell me about your
son stuck
in um great kid I mean couldn't ask for
any better kid through school and stuff
like that he has
no ambition he didn't want to go to
college um and I wasn't going to push
him uh you know used to send him to
drink beer for three or four years um
what's he do so he he got him a job
working at a same Factory where my wife
works at making what kind of
money um he's
1850 1875 something like that right
now so you know what's he going to do
with his
life well he doesn't know yet so you led
the question how bad of an idea is it
and I'm not trying to read too much into
that but me think some reason that makes
think it's a bad idea why do you think
it's a bad idea yeah what's going on
well I mean just just handing handing an
18-year-old kid a a house um you know
the financial responsibilities it it
needs it it hasn't had anything done to
it since the 80s um it is stuck in the
60s from when it was built um wood
pantling uh acoustic tile SE ceilings I
mean honestly to to make it a a really
good flippable house I mean it needs to
be
gutted so but but he could sell it today
for 100k
I I I think I think it would bring a
100,000 right now just the way it says
needing to be flipped yes so really the
thing is this 18-year-old kid is making
$18 at the factory and we don't know
what he's going to do with his life
you're handing him
$100,000 yeah basically yes yeah you are
because he could sell it right after you
hand it to
him yeah he he
could I don't think he would I don't
think he would do my thing was was that
you know if it was it was gifted to me
and my brother by my mom you know she
claimed it to us 10 years ago um so we
have we
have well no no but you know if if we
sold it it would all it would all be you
know Capal gains um every bit of it if I
give it to him if it's his for if he
holds it for two years then he could
sell it as his primary residence and and
that capital gains would be gone yeah
that's true you don't have capital gains
on it though you're I mean unless you
got did you get it as an inheritance or
did she give it to you prior to death
she just just just private she mom's
still living but she just she just Beed
it she deed it to yeah that well you are
right then you've analyzed that properly
then yeah I wouldn't do it if I were you
trusting you I would you would yeah I'd
give it to him really yeah but I'm going
to put some terms on it here's my terms
okay I want to hear this okay I want him
to have a plan yes for his life right
and for the renovation of the
property right that's his sign that he
and and the third thing is he promises
never to borrow any
money I'm yep I I agree with that I want
I want to see a plan for renovation I
want to see a plan for your
life and um and and you sign a letter
that says I promise Dad uncle and Granny
I'm never going to borrow money I'm
going to use this as a way to become
wealthy I'm going to live here I'm going
to renovate it I'm going to sell it for3
or $400,000 in 3 or 4 years after I
fixed it up and pay no capital gains on
it meantime I'm going to have a career
and I'm going to go do something and be
somebody I don't I don't want him 38
years old working I don't want him 38
years old still working
there I want him to go do something with
his life don't you yeah I do I do too
but you know uh uh hey Bill today's 18
let me ask you this 15y old boys just
don't have that drive anym they or a lot
of them some do it's not about this
it's about the person in the environment
my question is do you think your son be
really honest do you think your son will
honor that agreement that Dave laid out
I like that agreement do you think your
son will honor it yes I yeah I do okay
I'd like to see him have some more
hardship I don't disagree with Dave's
conditions I love Dave's deal but I'd
like to see an 18-year-old have to have
to work hard save for something giving
him that is a big Leap Forward might let
him live there for a year rentree uh
with the promise of giving it to him if
he does a couple of these things I want
him to do something hard yeah let's
let's let's put a little skin in the
game yeah but I'm I'm old like that none
of this is anything except I just don't
want I want this to be a blessing and
not a curse it's a curse if he says
since I don't have rent I don't have to
work much and I don't have to work hard
and I can sit here in the old wood
paning and drink beer all weekend and
that's worse than having sent him to
school to to drink beer for 3 years so
that's what you don't want to do so if
you get something where we put him up on
a track and he is an obligation that
he's going to fulfill for his own good
MH then that's good but may maybe let
him sit there a year and at the end of
that year we will de it to you if you
are doing these three things uh you're
promising not to borrow money you have a
a game plan to do the renovation then
you've already begun some of the light
work on the renovation while you're
there and uh I want to see some movement
in your career I want you get up off
your little butt and getting gear and if
you're going to do all that we're going
to give you a free house buddy if you're
not then you're going to go be somewhere
else m MH I like that might might go for
a year on it and try I want to use it as
leverage to get him moving that's where
I'm at I want gumption I need that's an
old word we don't use a lot but I think
I want to see gumption out of the kid
and I think the dad is worried about
that yeah he well he's just worried yeah
the downside is is if you you know it's
the a miniature version of a trust fund
baby not quite but I mean I agree that's
why I wouldn't give it to him yet yeah I
think I think put some stipulation on
maybe do a delayed handoff that kind of
thing that I like the idea of where it
could take him mathematically if he
plays through and what you're saying
bill is very true he holds it two years
he sells it he's going to have all that
money taxfree it's a taxfree up to
250,000 gain and it'll probably be a
full gain uh for a single if he's
married by then you know it would be uh
500,000 that he can make on that house
and have no taxes so yeah Fix It Up live
there till he's 25 he's married and he
makes some serious bank and by then his
career has taken off because he's got a
whole game plan he's got he's got up and
got moving and yeah I like that that
that kind of create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life